toutes les critiques envers le régime sont
écrasées pendant des années. L'Arabie
saoudite a été critiquée pour sa
mainmise sur les militants des droits de l'homme qui les emprisonnent
et les torturent aujourd'hui, bien que l'
emprise du royaume sur ses citoyens s'étende
même au-delà de ses frontières, le
gouvernement essaie de faire taire tout le monde
qu'ils soient à l'intérieur ou à
l'extérieur du pays ils aiment utiliser la peur pour
faire taire tout le monde les menaces que je
reçois au quotidien sur mon
compte Twitter dans mon youtube v retourner mon
snapchat même en exil les critiques du
régime restent des cibles et leurs  les
chiffres augmentent, surtout ici au Canada, mon
père n'est plus silencieux Je suis prêt à
parler et à dire ce qui se passe réellement en
Arabie saoudite, c'est comme le
royaume du silence qui vit maintenant dans la
région de Toronto La Russie al-idrisi
reçoit des insultes et des menaces depuis  années,
ce sont des gens comme vous qui incitent les jeunes
hommes et femmes à désobéir à leur roi la
punition pour trahison est grande Raja
al-idrisi n'est qu'un  chien errant au Canada
quelqu'un me dit on va te tuer
ta vie vient de nous coûter comme une balle dans
la tête
elle est arrivée au Canada en tant que réfugiée il y a près de
20 ans elle se décrit comme une
dissidente saoudienne qui n'hésite pas à
s'opposer aux décisions prises  par le gouvernement,
elle a fui la plupart des menaces
via les médias sociaux parce que vous êtes maintenant
au Canada, vous pensez que vous êtes protégé,
mais un jour, vous devez venir au Moyen-
Orient, nous vous attraperons cette fois-là et
c'est ce qui s'est passé en 2017 Mohammed
bin Salman MBS  est le nouveau prince héritier
d'Arabie saoudite qui acquiert plus de pouvoir
sur le pays, il se présente comme
un réformateur, mais des dissidents comme Raja
continuent d'être ciblés lors d'un voyage en
Égypte pour voir son père mourant les
menaces virtuelles contre elle prendre une
nouvelle dimension bien plus réelle  car aza croit qu'elle
reconnaît l'un des hommes des
services de renseignement saoudiens, ils disent que non tu es arrivé en
Égypte, nous pourrions faire n'importe quoi avant
que tu ne retournes devant la caméra, tais-toi, ne
parle pas mal du  des
mois de gouvernement ont passé, puis en août 2018,
une crise diplomatique a éclaté entre le
Canada et l'Arabie saoudite dans un tweet Le
Canada a appelé les autorités saoudiennes à
libérer plusieurs militantes des droits des femmes récemment emprisonnées
, puis à ce qu'un tweet
comme celui-ci sorte de cette manière, la
perspective est scandaleuse
L'Arabie saoudite n'accepte pas de se faire dire
quoi faire par le Canada Riyad force le
départ de l'ambassadeur du Canada et
annonce le rapatriement de ses
étudiants ici sur Twitter Raja encourage
les étudiants à rester au Canada ses
efforts ne passent pas inaperçus en Arabie
saoudite
dit-elle  elle a rapidement reçu un appel
de sa famille si Raja préfère un
style de dissidence plus discret
on ne peut pas en dire autant de Ghanim al moosari qui
utilise un humour provocateur coupant pour faire valoir
son point les saoudiens la famille royale saoudienne
ils pensent qu'ils sont au dessus d'une
critique ils pensent  personne
n'aura le courage de se moquer d'eux, il a
quitté l'Arabie saoudite en 2003 et vit à
Londres maintenant sa vidéo  os se moquant de la
famille royale ont tiré leur part de menaces
j'ai un ami qui me rend visite du Canada
et nous sommes allés dans un café cet ami est
Alan Bender un homme d'affaires spécialisé dans les
négociations pour les entreprises nord-
américaines cherchant à faire des affaires au
Moyen-Orient en
août dernier il  J'étais à Londres avec Ghanim
lorsque deux Saoudiens l'ont poursuivi, je pense que
nous avons marché pendant environ moins d'une minute
ou deux et c'est à ce moment-là qu'ils ont commencé
à lui crier dessus en criant
qu'ils m'ont attaqué verbalement et physiquement en
disant que Qui suis-je pour parler de la
famille royale saoudienne  ils ont essayé de l'
attaquer plusieurs fois mais je les ai arrêtés
mais l'un d'eux a réussi à se glisser
derrière moi et à frapper le Ghanim Ganim est
convaincu que cette attaque a été orchestrée
par les autorités saoudiennes
c'est un message à tout dissident que nous
pouvons vous joindre si vous en avez assez  à l'étranger
même si vous êtes sur la police britannique a ouvert une
enquête sur l'incident jusqu'à présent
aucune arrestation n'a été faite le gouvernement a
envoyé deux représentants et un de m  y
frères et ils l'ont envoyé à Montréal
pour faire ou organiser une rencontre avec moi
plus près de chez moi au Québec Omar Abdul Aziz
s'est également retrouvé pris dans les
tentacules du régime saoudien il a parlé
avec nos collègues de CBC
ils n'essayaient pas de  me convaincre de
revenir nous voulons changer le système nous
voulons faire des choses pour les jeunes pour les
jeunes j'ai dit merci pour cela
mais je ne peux pas revenir en arrière après son refus
il dit que ses amis et deux
frères à la maison ont été arrêtés je ne l'ai pas fait  Je ne pense
pas qu'ils vont faire du mal à un
membre de la famille des amis des innocents n'ont
rien à voir avec la politique l'emprise
sur Omar continue de se resserrer il
apprend que son téléphone est infecté par un
logiciel permettant à quelqu'un d'espionner
toutes ses communications je dirais avec
certitude  le gouvernement saoudien derrière ça et
vous savez ce qui est vraiment vous savez que ça
me rend triste parce que maintenant je ne sais pas
combien de personnes sont en danger une de
ces personnes
Jamal chut ji
avec Omar les deux ont échangé sur divers
des projets dont un pour fournir des
cartes SIM à des collaborateurs leur permettant d'
utiliser des médias sociaux non retracés par les
autorités saoudiennes l'objectif était de contrer ce que
certains appellent les comptes pro-régime Flies
qui inondent chaque jour les dissidents d'
insultes sur Twitter ou d'autres
réseaux sociaux en décembre dernier Omar  partagé certains
de ces échanges avec Herschel G avec
CNN comme celui-ci où le journaliste
décrit le prince héritier comme une bête à la
recherche de victimes messages qui auraient
pu être interceptés à Riyad le
piratage de mon téléphone a joué un rôle majeur
sur ce qui est arrivé à Jamal I  Je suis vraiment
désolé de dire que le téléphone de Ganon Alma désolé erreur
a également été ciblé par des logiciels espions, tout
comme le téléphone d'un autre dissident bien connu
vivant à Londres.
ville a quitté l'Arabie Saoudite en 2013
il a depuis fondé une organisation de
défense des droits de l'homme à travers ses
contacts il espère sensibiliser d'autres
gouvernants  ts aux problèmes en Arabie
Saoudite quand j'ai publié ces photos
il y a beaucoup de gens qui
disent de moi c'est un traître il
travaille pour notre ennemi et nous n'avons pas besoin
de pitié pour le traître
nous devons tuer tous les traîtres assassinats
spyware  emprisonnement des membres de la famille insultes
et menaces de mort malgré tout pour
ces dissidents le combat doit continuer
quelqu'un doit dire non quelqu'un doit
s'arrêter contre cela la vraie réforme doit
commencer par libérer tous les prisonniers d'
opinion permettre aux gens de leur accorder la
liberté d'expression en tant que  Michele Faust,
rapporteur spécial auprès de l'ONU,
est en contact régulier avec de
nombreux défenseurs des droits de l'homme,
même si de nombreux dissidents sont
déterminés à aller de l'avant, d'autres ont
été ébranlés par le meurtre de Jamal
Hazuki, ils me préservent Lito. J'ai rencontré de
nombreux dissidents qui depuis ce  arrivé
m'ont dit qu'ils ont plus peur qu'avant
alors à Allah qui tu es dieu de
Séville ils vérifient derrière eux dans la
rue pour voir s'ils sont en train d'être  suivis
et voyagent parfois sous différentes
identités pour éviter d'être suivis ils
sont longs serait-il plus
difficile en ce moment d'obtenir des informations
de l'intérieur car la cyberattaque et les
personnes dont ils s'inquiètent si le
gouvernement les espionne également après les
arrestations massives et il y a  la répression
contre les défenseurs des droits de l'homme
c'est vraiment rendre notre mission plus
difficile
2017 l'arabie saoudite et son prince
héritier projettent une nouvelle image plus moderne
et ouverte sur le monde les prix du pétrole ont
baissé et le royaume veut
diversifier son économie les femmes auront
le droit  conduire et les cinémas vont
commencer à ouvrir on sent que l'Arabie Saoudite
voulait montrer qu'elle faisait des progrès
que le nouveau chef du pays était
progressiste LDPE Daghestan L'Arabie Saoudite
voulait être un pays modéré normal
Denis horik a été l'ambassadeur du Canada
en Arabie Saoudite de 2015 à  2018
persona non grata là puisque le célèbre
peut même tweeter en août dernier la réalité
est la pe  programme de réforme que le
prince héritier a mis dans la vision 2030, il couvre
un vaste domaine d'activité allant de la
réalisation du système éducatif à
la diversification économique ouvrant
un espace de divertissement comme vous l'avez dit, mais ce
qu'il n'est pas et n'a jamais été d'ouvrir
un espace politique pour mettre  c'est grossièrement c'est que
tu sais tais-toi et va au cinéma
cet homme ne cherchait rien de plus que
ça
pas même un dissident à distance il menait une
vie tranquille en Arabie Saoudite mais même pour
quelqu'un comme lui une petite erreur peut être
très coûteuse pour protéger son  amis et
famille toujours à la maison, nous l'appellerons
Sayid,
nous avons également modifié de petits détails de
son histoire pour éviter la reconnaissance de l'
intelligence ouais ils sont venus me voir, nous
savons ce que vous avez fait et nous savons quand et
où vous pensiez que
Sayid appartenait à la minorité chiite en  Arabie
Saoudite Je fais partie de ces milliers de
personnes qui ont pris la parole mais ma faute c'est que j'ai
parlé au mauvais endroit
selon lui ses ennuis ont commencé
quand il a critiqué le régime alors que
parler à des collègues de travail l'un d'
eux a rapporté ce que le site avait dit aux
autorités je pensais que la période que nous avons
passée ensemble en tant que collègues le
fera au moins se taire ou me pardonnera au
moins mais il n'a pas pris le parti de dénoncer
la répression du gouvernement contre  la
communauté chiite ainsi que son
intervention armée au Yémen ce qui s'est passé au
Yémen qui était vraiment un désastre L'
Arabie saoudite a été largement critiquée
pour son rôle dans la guerre au Yémen l'une
des pires crises des droits de l'homme au
monde aujourd'hui quand j'ai perdu mon emploi le
la raison en était que j'ai dit peu
de temps après qu'un agent des renseignements saoudiens
contacte le côté avec un message qu'il m'a dit que
vous savez que les traîtres dans n'importe quel endroit
du monde ont une punition, donc je savais
qu'il voulait dire que je pourrais être tué, vous
devez coopérer avec nous alors  nous pouvons
vous pardonner qu'ils veulent que j'espionne
certaines personnes depuis que Mohammed bin Salman a
pris le pouvoir et a promis des réformes une
modernisation de l'État en effet
ce que nous avons vu à Amnesty
I  L'international c'est plus la reprise de la
répression contre les dissidents même les
chefs religieux critiques du régime peuvent être
arrêtés mais l'année dernière c'est l'
emprisonnement de plusieurs militants des droits de l'
homme qui a défrayé la chronique
parmi eux Lou Jane al Haq Lula
diplômée de l'université britannique
Columbia Samar a été la première femme à
poursuivre son tuteur et Samar Badawi qui
était au centre du
tweet controversé du Canada en Arabie saoudite, nous
n'avons aucune information précise
sur leur bien-être, évidemment nous sommes
très inquiets car il y a eu des
allégations de  les mauvais traitements dans les
prisons saoudiennes ce n'est pas une question de droits c'est
une question de sécurité nationale
Dennis horik connaissait certaines des femmes
arrêtées qu'il a du mal à comprendre ou une
menace qu'elles auraient pu représenter pour la sécurité nationale
J'ai du mal à croire être
parfaitement honnête d'après ce que j'ai  les
connaissaient, leur ordre du jour était de changer en Arabie
saoudite, mais de changer dans le sens qui
avait déjà commencé en termes de condition féminine
droits à Turin en termes de modification des
lois sur la tutelle qui ont à voir
avec divers contrôles que les hommes exercent
sur les femmes en Arabie saoudite en 2014, une
loi radicale sur l'antiterrorisme y a été
adoptée à peu près toutes les formes de
dissidents et d'opposition au  état
tomber sous la bannière du terrorisme toute
pensée l'une des premières victimes de
cette loi était l'avocat Waleed Abu al Kyra
Samar Badawi ex-mari il représentait aussi l'
un des
prisonniers d'opinion les plus reconnus certains sont mais son
frère
- sommes-nous emprisonnés depuis 2012  brefs
appels une ou deux fois par semaine selon
son moral et sahadev raves sa femme
vit à Sherbrooke avec leurs trois
enfants depuis 2013 ray s'il écrivait pour
les droits humains et les droits des femmes pour la
liberté de conscience appelle des talons pour
ses écrits
Rafe a été condamné à  1 000 coups de fouet dix
ans de prison et dix
ans supplémentaires sans quitter le pays comme
beaucoup d'autres et saath avait récemment vu de nombreux
signes prometteurs do we d  o repas
depuis 2017 il y a eu beaucoup de
changements en Arabie Saoudite comme les femmes
ont maintenant le droit de conduire et il y a des
cinémas en Arabie Saoudite la
police religieuse a moins de pouvoir qu'avant les
capacités de la police utilisaient minuit mais il y
a eu des incidents qui se sont produits
comme les problèmes avec le Canada la mort
du journaliste Jamel khashoggi donc on
ne sait pas ce qui va se passer après ça
la démocratie des journalistes
cas du caucus Ossipon un oppresseur vivant malgré ses
inquiétudes elle espère que son mari
sera libéré elle a été encouragée par une
récente réunion  avec le premier ministre
Justin Trudeau à Sherbrooke
il m'a promis qu'il ferait quelque chose le plus
tôt possible
c'est le cas le cas le plus
célèbre arrêter quelqu'un de symbolique comme
ça c'est une façon d'envoyer un message à d'
autres nous sommes allés après lui alors assurez-vous
que si vous continuez vos activités
il y aura un prix à payer
alors que les fameuses affaires font la
une des journaux d'autres Saoudiens pris dans les
griffes de la ré  gime vivre leur drame
dans l'anonymat complet ils ne m'ont pas tué
parce qu'à ce moment-là ils avaient besoin de
quelqu'un de ma ville pour coopérer avec
eux à cause de ma faute ils avaient aussi besoin de
ma femme pour coopérer avec eux
Syed et sa femme devraient espionner les
membres  de leur communauté, je savais que
lorsque j'espionnerais, je ferais du mal à ces personnes,
ces personnes seraient en danger, ces
personnes seraient arrêtées, torturées ou
tuées, alors moi et ma femme, nous avions le
choix difficile de rester et de
coopérer ou de nous échapper, nous avons décidé de nous
échapper.  C'était difficile de choisir ça, mais ce sera
plus difficile de rester et de coopérer parce que
c'est comme mettre du sang dans ta main pour
faire partie de ce gouvernement
soupir et sa famille puce l'Arabie Saoudite
quelque chose qu'il n'aurait jamais imaginé faire non non
pas même pour une seconde je suis  pas d'accord avec
certains problèmes mais c'est ton pays tu
veux rester avec tes amis et ta
famille la société qui t'a élevé quand
je vois ces gens qui se sont échappés
je ne peux pas imaginer leur sentiment mais maintenant
je suis à leur place  Jim Apple halwa Jay
Venkata J'ai décidé de quitter l'Arabie saoudite
parce qu'il n'y a pas de loi pour protéger une
femme là-bas en avril dernier
Salwa al Zahrani et sa jeune sœur ont
fui l'Arabie saoudite au milieu de la
nuit, elles veulent apparaître qu'une femme a
vécu une bonne vie  et avaient-ils
leurs droits, ils conduisent en quelque sorte, ils peuvent
trouver un emploi, mais savent en fait que
seules les quelques femmes pures pour s'échapper, elle a
dû voler son propre passeport
au domicile de son frère et réserver secrètement des
billets d'avion, une
simple erreur peut avoir besoin de mettre fin à mon  la vie
fuir sa famille sans que personne ne le
sache, c'est aussi ce que Rajas mohammed a fait
en janvier Je ne pars pas tant que je n'ai pas vu le
HCR
J'y suis allé alors que je m'arrêtais dans un hôtel en
Thaïlande la jeune de 18 ans a diffusé
son message dans le monde entier en quelques jours
avec le  L'aide de Twitter dans une actualité nationale de l'
université lundi La statue de Davila éblouit les nouvelles de la nouvelle école de
Mizenko Ivo Alpha dans une interview avec la
CBC, elle raconte avoir été victime
de violence aux mains de sa famille  y
à Haïfa, j'ai dû risquer ma vie
pour obtenir ma liberté, comment cela s'est-il passé,
mais ma plus grande peur était que s'ils me trouvaient,
je disparaîtrais bien comme Massada si
quelqu'un me reprenait, je serai emprisonné
pendant six mois et avec 18  avec 80
coups de fouet le nombre de Saoudiens fuyant
leur pays augmente tout comme le
nombre de demandes d'asile au Canada le
nombre a augmenté de manière quasi constante
au cours des dix dernières années pour atteindre 362 en
2017 en septembre 2018 plus de 400
demandes étaient encore devant l'
Immigration and  Commission des réfugiés du Canada
selon l'ONU Le Canada se classe au deuxième rang
pour le nombre de demandeurs d'asile en provenance d'
Arabie saoudite juste derrière les États-
Unis c'est comme une réputation pour le Canada
ils ont le côté humanité
c'est maintenant un réfugié ici au Québec la
récente augmentation des demandes ne  ne le
surprenez pas, ils augmentent parce que
l'arrivée de NBS rend le pays
vivant là-bas plus difficile qu'avant
Salwa est également maintenant au Canada, elle espère
obtenir le statut de réfugié a s  tatus raha
a déjà prévu de continuer son
combat pour les femmes mais d'ici au Canada
en Arabie Saoudite je ne pourrais
rien faire définitivement c'étaient des femmes
avant moi qui ont essayé de changer les choses mais
elles sont maintenant en prison et elles
sont exposées  à la torture et je ne
veux pas être comme ça on ne peut pas nier qu'il
y a un problème la communauté regarde les
ONG publier des rapports mais ils refusent de
reconnaître publiquement qu'il y a un problème
depuis que le Canada a demandé à l'Arabie Saoudite de libérer
ses militants des droits de l'homme diplomatique
les tensions persistent les pourparlers se poursuivent entre
les deux pays mais il n'y a toujours pas d'
ambassadeur canadien en place à Riyad
car pour les étudiants saoudiens certains ont été
autorisés à terminer leurs études au
Canada nous avons contacté les
affaires étrangères saoudiennes pour commentaires mais nos
demandes sont restées sans réponse un autre
journaliste Khashoggi dit  ils
veulent absolument dire sauf que vous n'existez que
appelé le maire s'est opposé à allaha, de même que le
Canada fait partie des pays appelant
à un thoro  euh enquête sur le
meurtre de Jamar hisagi chef Casey :
Monsieur Solaris alman un contrôle PNG le
Sagarika Chacon a vu des réserves apparemment
Ottawa examine également ses
permis d'exportation pour les véhicules blindés légers canadiens
vers l'Arabie saoudite un contrat d'une
valeur de quinze milliards de dollars ce qui
s'est passé avec le Canada  alors ce qui est arrivé
au jihad a révélé tout ce que le gars qui
veut montrer comme l'homme qui réformera
le système saoudien est exposé à
la réalité
personne ne peut reformater les jours noirs
arrivent pour lui je ne pense pas que ça
va être un  caïman mais tout le monde n'est pas
convaincu que ça ne va nulle part
les Saoudiens ne laisseront pas le monde dicter
qui dirige leur pays, peu importe ce que
l'avenir réserve à NBS ses
détracteurs continueront à se faire entendre
Je ne suis pas découragé et je continuerai à
faire quoi  Je le fais, c'est seulement que je dois
être plus prudent, je ne serais pas surpris
si une partie de la distance serait un peu
plus calme, certains pourraient simplement réagir co  complètement à l'
opposé et c'est en quelque sorte la loi
des conséquences involontaires comme si
vous saviez en fermant en essayant de faire taire
un homme qu'ils ont déchaîné des déserts
Je crois que le régime saoudien devrait se sentir
plus qu'avant en ce moment Je crois
que c'est notre moment en ce moment  le
régime saoudien devrait avoir comme plus peur
nous dire nous sommes forts
[Musique]